jennifer aniston courtney cox and lisa
kudrow reunited to celebrate the fourth
of july
oh i love you i love you
[Music]
courtney posted a selfie with her
friends co-stars posing with big smiles
as the caption wished fans a happy 4th
xoxo and we're just going to say it this
is the one where they celebrated the
fourth of july
really does put me in a better mood
jen and lisa were matching in blacktops
with gold jewelry
while their hostess wore a tan blouse
and hoop earrings
their smiling selfie also featured
summer ready accessories as
jen had a pair of sunglasses on her head
and lisa rocked a sun hat
i'm really excited yeah but the french
stars weren't the only a-listers at
courtney's party
she also invited laura dern who arrived
festive wearing a red sweater
the big little lies star posted this
photo to her instagram writing
happy fourth from moscow's wow the
holiday hangout comes after the ladies
plus matthew perry
matt leblanc and david schwimmer came
together for the highly anticipated
friends reunion
oh my god here we go
where's the tissue box
[Music]
the cost of friends shooting that
shooting any of it being in the same
room with these people and getting to
hug them
that was the best in may ity sat down
with the whole cast and they opened up
about
how emotional it was to be together on
the same set 17 years after the show
wrapped
how amazing was it actually to be back i
know you guys are friends anyway to be
back in this set on the set with you all
together kind of in this zone again
it was the most emote i i i had slept so
well the night before
woke up i wasn't nervous at all just
feeling good the first question like
how do you feel i was like and then
started crying over the 10 years
obviously we we really
grew close as a family and part of the
reason was that
that initial success of the show was
something that no other
no one else could relate to or or was
going through except the other five
actors so
um we really we really got close because
of
that experience too all i can say is
that there was something
that was laid down at the very very
beginning that kind of went into our
neural pathways that we
instantly it was in our dna that we were
family we were going to take care of
each other
it's unexplainable but we're the most
grateful
women that i know who have been able to
be a part of something like this
[Music]
you